Donald Trump at 9 00 PM Eastern tonight
will be making an announcement the
expectation is that he's going to
announce he's running for president
although there are many people telling
him don't do it at least don't do it yet
Donald Trump in his infinite delusions
of grandeur is saying that hopefully
this announcement will be one of the
most important days in American history
think about that Donald Trump believes
that whatever he's going to say tonight
and we will carry it live
is going to be one of the most important
days in the history of the United States
talk about narcissism Donald Trump
posting yesterday on his platform truth
social truth essential quote hopefully
tomorrow will turn out to be one of the
most important days in the history of
our Capital C country and then again
today Trump posting hopefully today will
turn out to be one of the most important
days in the history of our country
however not everybody thinks this is a
good idea Donald Trump's final former
press secretary Kaylee mcenany says
Trump should not declare today take a
listen to this and that could go
straight through the state of Georgia
does that include Trump I think he needs
to put it on pause absolutely look he'll
make that decision
but does he go to advising any Contender
to Santa's Trump whomever no one
announces 2024 until we get through
December 6th do you see the former
president I need for him to go to
Georgia I I think we've got to make
strategic calculations um Governor
DeSantis I think he should be welcome to
the state given what happened last night
you gotta look at the reality is on the
ground and Herschel Walker we've got to
win the Senate that's it guys got to win
the Senate all right we'll move on uh
the Democrats first yeah so Kaylee
doesn't think this is such a good idea
at least not before the December 6th uh
runoff now some have speculated that
Trump is going to change his plan
tonight and instead will announce
something about Herschel Walker however
he's already scamming people out of
money claiming it'll go to Herschel
Walker it'll go mostly to him I'll get
to that in a moment another person who
doesn't think Trump should be announcing
tonight is uh Republican Governor John
sununu take a listen to this I know you
say the media loves to talk about Donald
Trump and perhaps that's fair but it's
not not just the media it's Donald Trump
himself and he's planning to announce
for president sorry guys it's Chris
sununu I apologize Chris is that a good
idea
uh for him no I think it's a terrible
idea for him I was look from just in
purely political standpoint uh we we
still don't know what's going to happen
in Georgia the votes are still being
counted in Nevada and and and Arizona by
the way no Nevada and Arizona yeah
is still undecided yeah only about 80 80
or 90 and so we'll see where that goes
but look people want to move away from
Politics as you hit Thanksgiving as you
hit Christmas as we're spending time
with families as we're trying to figure
out how we're going to fill our oil
tanks with all these high fuel prices so
now's just a horrible time for big
political uh statements uh you save that
for early 23 would be be my message but
either way it doesn't really matter it's
it's going to be great for the media
Saturday Night Live we'll we'll probably
love it uh but for the rest of us we're
going to focus on spending time with our
families all right so Chris sununu does
not think Trump should announce his run
for presidency tonight and here is Jason
Miller one of Donald Trump's for a while
closest advisors he appeared on Newsmax
and he also said I wouldn't make this
announcement on November 15th today now
you just said everything over the next
month is about Herschel Walker having
said that I understood there could have
could be an announcement uh before that
uh from somebody that resides at Marvel
so does that change his plans as far as
announcing
so no formal decision yet of course
president Trump had said that he would
be making an announcement on November
15th next Tuesday I'm advising the
president to hold off until after the
Georgia race after Herschel Walker
priorities a b and c need to be about
Herschel right now this is bigger than
anything else in the country we got to
show the focus is on Georgia Keep the
Country rallying in a really critical
point here is that Brian Kemp holds many
of the cards for what's going to happen
with Herschel Walker there were a lot of
the Kemp Warnock ticket Splitters Kemp
didn't do anything for Herschel Walker
in the general election if Kemp wants to
show that he's a leader with some
brighter future ahead of him then he
needs to get out there and really hustle
for a Herschel Walker we need all hands
right so the point here is Jason Miller
is advising Trump not to do it but there
is one person who thinks it would be a
great idea it happens to be Donald
Trump's daughter-in-law Lara Trump when
asked given the poor results in the
midterms should Donald Trump really be
announcing and said absolutely I don't
think there's ever been a better time to
be honest with you for Donald Trump to
come back everywhere I go and I live in
obviously a very Republican state in the
State of Florida all I hear from people
is we need Donald Trump back we want him
back please tell us he's running
um so I don't think you can believe all
the headlines yep in her weird Echo
chamber bubble where she lives Lara
Trump thinks there is no better time
than right now for Donald Trump to
announce we will carry the event I'm not
even calling it the announcement anymore
the event tonight including reaction we
will be going live at 8 pm Eastern the
announcements at 9pm Eastern join me on
YouTube twitch and Facebook and remember
if you're not subscribed on YouTube you
really should be youtube.com the David
packman show the science tells us that
one of the best ways to get consistent
deep sleep is lowering your core body
temperature when your body stays cooler
at night you're more comfortable and
your sleep is better our sponsor sleep
me is the home of Chilly sleep the
customizable climate controlled sleep
solutions that can improve your sleep by
keeping you cooler at night there are
three different chili sleep systems
there's the uler the cube and the new
Doc Pro with double the cooling power
all three systems are water-based
temperature controlled mattress toppers
that fit over your existing mattress to
provide you with your ideal sleep
temperature you can go as cool as 55
degrees you can go really hot if you
want I keep mine at 60 beautiful
temperature for me
don't wake up hot and sweaty chilly
sleep keeps me asleep all night it feels
great I didn't know it was possible to
love sleeping even more than I already
did go to sleep.me slash Pacman to learn
more and get 25 off your new chili Sleep
System click the link below to start
staying cool at night